tonight E.T presents Michael J fox from
Teen Idol to Advocate it's all been one
kind of great ride we celebrate the man
living life with no regrets I'm just
having a good time why acting wasn't his
first career choice but super stardom
was his Destiny I think I'm a one in a
million shot where I paid off what you
never knew about Michael's private life
are you guys dating tonight we're
married she said you weren't gonna tell
no and public battles Progressive
degenerative incurable very rare Rio the
E.T Vault revealing four decades worth
of never before seen interviews who is
or was your favorite co-star to kiss my
wife
that's easy our time with the husband
the father and the fighter have had to
kind of make adjustments in my life to
be able to do my work still who is now
focused on changing the world it's a
bright future ahead ET Starts Now
from Alex P Keaton to Marty McFly
tonight we celebrate the one and only
Michael J fox welcome to Entertainment
Tonight of course April is Parkinson's
awareness month and Michael's new Apple
TV plus documentary still drops May 12th
but until then we're looking back at
et's 40 plus years of interviews with
the Beloved actor writer and producer
turned Parkinson's Advocate oh yeah but
let's not forget his first ever title
boy Prince of Hollywood
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
I'm 22 and and my energies right now I'm
focused on my career and trying to
figure out who I am I'm probably the
most anxious to see what is going to
happen I added it up on the way home Leo
I've been in seven jams in two weeks
Michael was just 15 years old when he
landed his first major role in the
Canadian sitcom Leo and me but acting
wasn't his first choice for a career I
wanted to play professional hockey and
my size seemed to be the biggest barrier
and then I got into drama and then I
found out if you made girls laugh you
you know and you collected more phone
numbers I was real lucky in that I
latched on to acting and really devoted
myself to it his devotion led to a
Crossroads in 1979 should he finish high
school or Chase's dream with the support
of his family Michael dropped out and
swapped the suburbs of Vancouver for the
bright lights of Hollywood I came down
to the States when I was 18 living on my
own and and and trying to make it as an
actor and playing you know Dodge the
landlord and you know things
borrowing people's phones and selling my
furniture and eating plain wrap tuna and
all that stuff I think I'm a one in a
million shot where I paid off it it took
Michael a few years
at his big
Keaton on Family Ties well how do I look
middle-aged
by 85 the sitcom was one of the most
watched shows on TV Teen Wolf and Back
to the Future were released the same
year and Michael went from TV star to
Teen Idol almost overnight when was the
first time you got sort of mobbed by
fans I was in New York and I was walking
down the street and this little girl she
wanted to marry me and all that she was
weeping so I'm trying to calm her down
and finally I looked to her mother for
support and her mother was weeping and
so I thought I'm in trouble the Newfound
attention led to a roster of
high-profile girlfriends including
Jennifer Gray Sarah Jessica Parker and
Facts of Life star Nancy McKeon then at
the 1986 Oscars you're dating Michael J
fox tonight tonight are you guys dating
tonight
we're married
where are you
rumors even twirled about his family
Ty's love interest Courtney Cox he's a
really nice person to work with anyway
and so I I feel the chemistry's there
in terms of you know Michael Fox and
Courtney Cox and having an affair that's
so predictable and untrue that it's
boring and just laughable
the past two hours E.T was on set with
the Family Ties cast during season one
in 1982 where we first saw Michael up
close and personal as everyone's
favorite young Republican Alex P Keaton
but get this he had to fight for an
audition they had made an offer to
Matthew Broderick who had turned it down
NBC's Executives were a tough sell too
they thought at five foot four Michael
was too short to be believable as the
son of his TV dad Michael Gross who
stood a foot taller but Fox's fresh face
made it possible for him to play a high
schooler even though he was 21. I think
there are limitations with my size and
with the way I look but um there there
aren't any limitations with the things I
want to do you know Michael's boys charm
made Family Ties must-see TV the show's
momentum even helped launch the careers
of guest stars like Tom Hanks Christina
Applegate Julia Louis Dreyfus and Gina
Davis
was that cool to kiss her once I get off
the ladder another on-screen love
interest his future wife Tracy Poland
she played Allen who was Alex's first
real serious girlfriend what was your
first impression of each other you have
said you thought he was cocky no he was
a fact he was very young and he was very
very successful and he had like three
cars you know
I'm seeing you in the waiting room and I
wanted to just walked in I said Caster
all right she looks great
Family Ties collected a total five Emmy
Awards three of which went to Michael he
also earned his first Golden Globe for
the show's final season in 1989. more
than 36 million fans tuned in for the
series finale what an Incredible Gift
this has been thank you to all the
people who've watched the show you know
you've you've made my life great and I
appreciate it but one little known fact
during the height of his family ties
Fame Michael started working on his
movie career shooting Back to the Future
it happened so quick certainly it was a
big step to do a
feature-length multi-million dollar film
Michael actually wasn't the first one
cast as teenage time traveler Marty
McFly nope that was his look-alike Eric
Stoltz who got fired several weeks into
filming as dramatic method actor he just
wasn't a good fit there was so little
time to really either
really think a lot about replacing
another actor maybe what he did and what
I shouldn't do boom I was there and and
doing it and then it was just staying
awake yep staying awake was the tough
part Michael was pulling double duty
working on Family Ties from ten to six
then driving to the movie Set where he'd
work until 2 A.M that went on for three
months in between takes I was sleeping I
was working at 16 18 20 hour days with
222 million at the box office Back to
the Future became the highest grossing
movie of 1985 worldwide turning Michael
into one of the most in-demand stars of
the decade
all right
I talk to you you become a bigger and
bigger star nope still 5'4 no between
1984 and the time Family Ties ended in
1989 Michael's career hit a Breakneck
Pace eight major movies in five years
including the Back to the Future sequels
which shot simultaneously over nearly a
year
ET was on set action
originally it was all one script and
there was just too much stuff and so
they made it into two you've got to come
back with me where Back to the Future it
basically continues where it left off
last time we go into the future because
something has to be done about my kids
I've been in part three it gets even
weirder there's a lot of character work
and a lot of makeup I play my son I play
my father mom
is that you playing a teenage girl you
know and um
I thought it was kind of cute yeah
Michael dressed in drag to play his own
daughter in Back to the Future too he
went outside his comfort zone again in a
handful of dramatic roles there was an
upside to playing a drug addicted writer
in the 1988 drama Bright Lights big city
reuniting with his future wife Tracy
pollen are you sure you're all right
well my brain is trying to find a way
out of his skull
fact that Tracy's my girlfriend was nice
the fact that she's an incredibly gifted
actress who I've been lucky enough to
work with before was better
who is or was your favorite co-star to
kiss my wife
that's easy I just remember that
terrifying for
anything else I'd ever done I am a very
nice person except when I'm around
people like you oh people like me people
like me I happen to like people like me
so I didn't start seeing her when she
was on the show yes it wasn't love at
first sight Miss Nancy McKeon and Mr
Michael Fox in fact at the Time Michael
was dating The Facts of Life star and
Tracy was in a long-term relationship
with footloose's Kevin Bacon so a couple
years later when I ran into her again
and we started seeing each other of all
the great things that have come from
this show Tracy obviously is by far and
away the best
[Music]
there for the couple's first red carpet
together at the Emmys the following July
their Vermont wedding created a media
frenzy photographers staked out the
ceremony on the ground and in the sky
so our wedding was another whole surreal
thing but it was great and it stuck
it took which is all that matters and
it's hard to believe but this summer
they'll celebrate their 35th Anniversary
she's my best friend
so sexy as hell and
sweating but as much as those two are
couples goals why don't we tell you
about their family Fox party of six I
mean I see people with their little
toddlers in the stores and then I want
to grab them and say you don't know how
fast this will go yeah this goes so fast
our favorite thing is just spending time
together as a family and they would say
the same thing yeah it's definitely true
it's really nice to be with both my
parents home-cooked meals are a really
big thing in our family so just like
sitting down at the dinner table and
like talking about our day twins Skyler
and aquina make up half the squad they
both work for media companies Esme the
youngest is at Duke eldest Sam who could
totally pass as his dad's doppelganger
is in Show Business too Sam Works in
Film Production and got a taste of the
business early on it's been fun doing
definitely more behind the scenes stuff
and and being a part of the industry but
in a way that's that's different from
what I grew up with I didn't bust my ass
so he could bust his ass and bust my ass
so he could take a break pick that
generational
generational uh vacations last month
Michael introduced fans to the newest
edition this
this pup blue
ties are strong and his kids say it all
comes down to two words dad jokes he
definitely has a problem where he can't
resist making a pun if it's available to
him which looks like he's in pain trying
not to say it
he embarrasses you yes absolutely
ah fatherhood the greatest gig in the
world we go from Michael the dad to
Michael the spin doctor
this is like stepping back in time
men like us have to keep looking
to the Future
all roads lead Back to the Future yes
Christopher Lloyd guest starred on
Michael's hit sitcom Spin City back in
1999. now the show was Fox's big TV
comeback since leaving Family Ties and
you know that E.T was always invited on
set and two take one and action
every week is an accomplishment every
week is a new little 22 minute movie am
I better at it I don't know do I have
more fun yeah this is great Michael's
inspiration to return to the small
screen came from an unlikely place I was
watching I said Man TV has changed you
can really you can really bust the form
and I and all of a sudden I realized
that the Jerry Seinfeld was the smartest
guy in the world and all of a sudden it
just all started you know click in my
head
that was the thing to do I feel good
thank you oh I'm having a blast I'm
having so much fun the show was a hit
from the start and Michael was nominated
for four straight Emmys winning one oh
and since he was also the show's
executive producer you can bet Michael
had a say in casting I can't believe
you're standing here we did this kissing
scene last night it was like this is so
sexy yeah it was pretty cool at the
height of the show's popularity in 1998
Michael publicly announced he had been
secretly battling Parkinson's disease
for seven years two years later he
announced he'd be leaving the show it's
bittersweet but um but I feel good about
the choice and uh and yeah people
couldn't have been more loving and
supportive
he also capped his final season with a
Golden Globe Michael J fox
to go up on that stage and to
and you know who's out there and to see
those people um stand up
I wouldn't do this
um
so deserving now while Hollywood
continues to celebrate Michael his
mission moving forward was clear find a
cure for Parkinson's all right
you're making me shake
seven now I definitely can't walk and
carry this thing so I asked that Tracy
the ones are gonna carry the weight
she is his Rock Michael J fox was
awarded the gene hirschold humanitarian
Oscar at the 2022 Governors awards for
his efforts in fighting Parkinson's
disease yeah it was presented to him by
his longtime friend and former co-star
Woody Harrelson now the duo worked
together on Michael's 1991 movie Doc
Hollywood I really like that movie and
that was the same year Michael was
diagnosed with young onset Parkinson's
at just 29 years old I need any life
insurance
what what he just came over one day and
said I am Woody and and I Think You're
great and I think you're really funny
and I said well this is the beginning of
a very nice friendship we've just been
hanging out ever since Michael was out
partying with his friend and co-star the
night before he noticed his first
symptom I was feeling a little
disoriented that's when I noticed my
pinky it was trembling twitching Auto
animated how long this has been going on
I wasn't exactly sure but now that I
noticed it I was surprised to discover
that I couldn't stop it initially he
blamed it on his hangover but a few
months later Michael's doctor gave him
the diagnosis that would change his life
for good I don't think I said anything I
don't think I felt anything the doctor
said some more words like young onset
Progressive degenerative incurable very
rare your age new drugs New Hope brain
surgery the air was sucked from my lungs
what was I gonna tell my wife I kept it
to myself for seven years no Michael
didn't hit the brakes on his career he
hit the gas taking any job he could get
against the wishes of his wife Tracy in
those seven years of Silence he appeared
in 12 movies and made a return to
Primetime TV in the physically demanding
Spin City every time he stepped on set
he did everything he could to keep his
Parkinson's a secret
I'm always calculating I'm always
figuring out how am I going to do this
thing that I need to do when do I take a
pill so it's a whole bag of tricks
before the public knew e.t's cameras
caught Michael using those tricks to
mask the symptoms of the incurable brain
disorder here you can see him holding
props to slow his tremors his pockets
became a tool to conceal his hands it's
hard for me to stay still into this for
other people to move stress is a symptom
multiplier your brain just goes no I you
know we're under siege the most
dangerous crutch of all alcohol he drank
to disassociate hiding empty bottles
from Tracy at home and the Habit took a
toll on their marriage one time I woke
up with a hangover and I expected Tracy
to be mad at me she wasn't angry she was
just bored and and that to me was more
frightening than anything I was
done I
know what this is now on you and you're
either gonna
do what you need to do or you're not
today Michael is more than three decades
sober once I looked at it I went this is
a direct reaction to this this diagnosis
that I haven't dealt with I haven't
really looked at that if I look at that
then everything else will fall into
place I don't think you helped someone
get through that that's that's a road
that everybody has to sort of go on
themselves but I was always there for
him Michael stepped back from acting
full time in 2000 to focus on a bigger
Mission finding a cure his foundation's
annual Gala has helped raise more than
1.5 billion dollars for high impact
research programs well the b word is
nice to see where it is going to be
better than cure
I've described
Parkinson's is is having Parkinson's as
being a gift and people think I'm nuts
and
you know yeah it's a gift that keeps on
taking but
but what it's what it's brought into my
life the giving and the thoughtfulness
and the empathy and the and the desire
to take action to help others to to be a
witness to that
is a great privilege
you know his fight is inspired so many
others
foreign
well that was a moment 25 years after
Back To The Future Three Marty and Doc
made a surprise visit to Jimmy Kimmel
Live back in 2015 DeLorean and all and
although Michael retired from acting
back in 2020 due to his declining help
he never missed an opportunity to
reunite with his back to the future
family I love that cast so much I could
watch that movie
here you go good night everybody
when I saw Chris at this in Comic-Con
I just
do my arms around with this because I
just don't have to see him he's going to
be this active being a guy who's kind of
like my brother
being a game to do that Father Figure
what's fun about Chris is that you never
know what Chris is going to do rose
we don't need roads it's about Spade in
heaven we have a good chemistry it's
automatic we all feel collectively that
we're involved with something that's
bigger than we are and none of us
expected this
[Music]